So, let's see if we can do
some MSI protocol transitions.
Let's say we have two cores
with private caches and
that the caches are using
MSI to maintain coherence.
Initially, block X is in memory and
no cache has it.
So here are the actions of
the caches in C1 and C2's cache.
Core 1 issues a read X.
Meanwhile, core 2 doesn't do anything.
What is the state of block X in C1's
cache after this read is completed?
And what is the state of
the block x in C2's cache,
after this read on C1 is completed?
So put your MS or I state here and
another one here.
Now, let's say that the next axis is
that C2 read X after this is completed,
what is the new state of X in C1 and
C2's cache?
And finally C1 does
another axis write X,
what is now the state in C1's cache
after this write is complete?
And what's the state in C2's cache
after this write on C1 is complete